[موسيقى]
الذين ظلموا تاهلت هذه المجموعه من حفظه
كتاب الله تعالى للمشاركه في المسابقه
الكبرى لحفظ القران الكريم وتلاوته
الله
وقد اختارت ان يكون التحضير للمسابقه في
احدى المدارس القرانيه التقليديه المعينه
على التركيز نظرا الى ابتعادها عن صخب
المدينه واحتفاظها بادوات التعليم المعينه
على الحفظ والمتوارثه عبر الاجيال
حسب لائحه المتنافسين فان عبد الرحمن ضمن
اول المشاركين الذين استدعتهم لجنه
التحكيم المشاركه وحدها هي فوز فعل
الحاضرين لكتاب الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يشاركوا في المسابقات وان يعطوا عنايه
القران وان يحضر للمسابقات فلها فوائد
كثيره
الشياطين
[موسيقى]
من امام لجنه التحكيميه يستحضر عبد الرحمن
كل مهاراته من اجل اتقان التلاوه وابراز
قدرته على الحفظ والتجويد الم
سابقه شارك فيها اكثر من 1800 حافظ تاهل
منهم نحو 150 الى التصفيات النهائيه من
فئات عمريه مختلفه يتنافسون على جوائز
نقديه وعينيه
تهدف هذه المسابقه الى خدمه كتاب الله عز
وجل
وتعزيز دوري خدمه القران الكريم في هذا
البلد
وكذلك ايجاد جو من التنافس بين حفظه كتاب
الله عز وجل
منبر اخر تتنافس فرق في الكلوريه لا
عصيتها في فن المديح النبوي خلال شهر
رمضان
[موسيقى]
السنه العاشره يسلم مركز ترانيم للفنون
الشعبيه في اعاده نشر عشرات القصائد
المديحيه بلهجه محليه مبسطه على ايقاع
ادوات موسيقيه تقليديه للحفاظ على هذا
التراث الشفوي ارتبط المدح عموما لدى
الموريتانيين باحياء الشهر الفضيل احياء
لياليك وجاء مهرجان
مركز ترانيم ليكون امتدادا لهذه العلاقه
الروحانيه من الموريتانيين وبين المدح
المصطفى صلى الله عليه وسلم خصوصا في شهر
رمضان المعظم
ويستمر السمر في نواكشوط حتى وقت متاخر من
الليل لتتيح الفضاءات المفتوحه فرصه
للتجمعات الاسريه ولقاءات الاصدقاء
وممارسه الرياضه
رغم سعي الموريتانيين للحفاظ على العادات
والتقاليد المرتبطه بالشهر الكريم فان
الواقع اظهر وجود طقوس جديده انعكست بشكل
كبير على مائده الافطار سنوات التربيه
الجزيره نواكشوط